all right let's get into audience
questions for the week we missed
audience questions last week because I
was traveling back and forth to LA in
the middle of the week that led to us
doing a sort of different Friday show
where I didn't take audience questions
but we're doing it this week the first
ones from esta Ville esta vel says hey
David do you think Joe Biden's strategy
of limited exposure will help him or
hurt him at the end or do you think
there's another reason for it such as
not having the energy and stamina to
campaign around the country I've seen no
evidence that there's an energy or
stamina issue with Joe Biden I think
that it is a calculated decision that
his team made although I would argue
incorrectly to sort of limit his
exposure until the debates start
presumably also doing debate prep to be
as best prepared as possible for the
debates that are scheduled to start in
at this point it's just a couple of
weeks I think that in the immediate it
did sort of work in the sense that
before his announcement Joe Biden was
polling in the low to mid 20s and after
his announcement Joe Biden started
polling as high as 40 or 41 percent in
some Democratic primary polls but that
has trailed off and Joe Biden has
dropped into the mid to low 30s in most
recent polls as Bernie Sanders has
regained momentum I know there were
people who will straight up say David
the polls are totally faked and
concocted and of course if that's the
case give me some evidence of that if we
accept that the polls are at least
generally right in terms of the momentum
of the race in terms of who's on the
upswing or the downswing what we've seen
is that recently Biden has started to
trail off from his post announcement
high whereas Bernie Sanders appiied
Budaj Edge has been on the rise lately
Elizabeth Warren has seen a slight
uptick in in the most recent couple of
weeks I don't think there is any reason
to think that the limited exposure
strategy for Joe Biden has worked
ultimately what this is going to come
down to is what happens once the debates
get going I've said before that Joe
Biden is a very good skilled debater
when it comes to one-on-one debates
against
if you look at what Joe Biden did with
Paul Ryan during that vice presidential
debate some years ago he mopped the
floor with Paul Ryan I mean it was an
embarrassing embarrassing experience for
Paul Ryan and Joe Biden did
extraordinarily well I am less confident
in Joe Biden's skills in a larger debate
against other Democrats particularly
when we know that Joe Biden is a
center-left candidate he is not the most
progressive candidate or anything close
to it and right now there is a hankering
among the Democratic among the
Democratic Party yeah for a more
progressive alternative to republicanism
and to establishment centrist Democrats
so although I have full confidence that
if Joe Biden is the nominee he will do
really well into debates against Donald
Trump this doesn't mean Joe Biden's
politics or my politics I am well to the
left of Joe Biden I'm analyzing what
will happen when the debates start I
think Biden would do really well against
Trump I am NOT super-confident and Joe
Biden's ability to do a really good job
against other Democrats particularly
other Democrats that are to Joe Biden's
left so we will see in the end what
happens with Joe Biden's strategy there
is no question that once the debates
start Joe Biden's low exposure strategy
is going to have to end if he wants to
maintain the lead that he has in the
Democratic primary period because other
candidates that are doing everything
from numerous town halls including in
read parts of the country like Elizabeth
Warren to a Fox News Town Hall like
Bernie Sanders to all sorts of different
shows ranging from Bill Maher to The
Breakfast Club like is Andrew yang even
though his polling numbers aren't great
I don't see how Joe Biden sticks it out
till the end with the limited exposure
strategy but we'll see if it pays
dividends for him in terms of allowing
debate prep between now and the start of
the Democratic debates